all right let's start today with a covid
update we haven't done this for a while
and increasingly the numbers in the
united states
are looking better and better as
vaccination takes place we've seen the
slowdown due to vaccine hesitancy we
will talk about it
we have also now seen evidence that the
vaccines work well
enough against all major variants we
will talk about
that momentarily but first of all cases
cases which peaked at more than 255
000 cases per day in mid-january an
outrageous
number uh not illegal but certainly an
immoral number as i like to say
cases are now down under 50 000 cases
per day
for the first time since october of 2020
it's been seven
months since cases have been this low
down to about 47 000 per day as of
yesterday
this is now down more than 80 percent
from the peak
in mid-january and these numbers should
continue down
and look even better by memorial day
certainly by mid-june
as far as deaths go deaths peaked in
late january
at nearly 3 500 deaths per day
more than a 911 every single
day and those are now also down more
than 80 percent to about
675 a day still horrible but
dramatically lower
and understand that daily deaths in the
u.s
have not been below 700 a day since
july of last summer so that is going
very much in the right direction deaths
as low as they've been in basically 10
months
now globally cases were coming down
and are coming down in the u.s globally
we did see a spike
led by countries like india and brazil
among others
that has also turned around not by much
but globally cases are now down about
three to four percent
from the peak that happened about 10
days ago we hope
that the global numbers will also uh
start coming down more significantly as
vaccines get to more and more countries
and we will speak momentarily about joe
biden coming out in support of lifting
or not enforcing patents on vaccines i
actually
don't think that's going to make a
difference but i'm going to tell you why
in the next segment
earlier this week i did tell you that
vaccination
is a growing problem in the sense that
supply is now exceeding demand in many
places
and we've seen average daily doses
decline from their high of about 3.4
million a day
now down to just 2.1 million doses per
day over the last week
that's not good but it will still get us
where we need to go as
long as it continues but the decline in
doses led joe biden to announce a new
vaccination initiative earlier this week
we talked about it yesterday
cvs pharmacy has already met the call
they are going to be offering
walk-in vaccination no appointment
necessary
at thousands of pharmacies across the
country
but the really good news about vaccines
is they work
on the variance of concern dr eric
topple former guest on the show
published yesterday a great infographic
showing us that of all of the relevant
variants so far
there's the british south african and
brazilian then there's the new york
california
and india variants we have at least some
evidence that the vaccines work
for example with the uk south africa and
brazil variants
we now have lab studies randomized
clinical trials
and real world evidence that the
vaccines work
well enough on those variants that if we
keep vaccinating we can get out of this
for the new york california and india
variants we don't yet have
the randomized controlled trials but we
have lab
studies and we have real world evidence
so we have a path out of this
moderna and pfizer at minimum are
working on boosters that will be tweaked
for the variants uh for the fall
or winter so the path is clear by
memorial day we will have a better
situation than we have today
and a little deeper uh you know early
summer
it will be even better if people keep
getting vaccinated
let's talk next about the patents
one of our sponsors today is blue blocks
i spend a lot of time because of my work
looking at a computer screen and peer
reviewed studies have shown
that the blue light that comes from
screens can actually lead to certain
types of eye strain and even damage
or blurred vision headaches dry watery
eyes
blue blocks fixes this by filtering out
the blue light
and unlike other cheap blue light
glasses the effectiveness of blue blocks
glasses
are backed up by evidence and they're
built under
optics laboratory conditions these are
my blue blocks glasses i like how they
look they have over 40 different styles
to choose from
i really have noticed a big difference
where i'm no longer
getting that eye strain and headaches
from the computer screen
because of the blue blocks glasses they
have prescription versions
and non-prescription and readers they
have something for every need
and blue blocks is giving you twenty
percent off
when you go to blue blocks dot com slash
pacman and use the code
pacman the link is under this video and
you'll get free shipping
on orders over a hundred and fifteen
dollars